[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream number 94 is it 94.
it's 95.
it's night welcome to the dark horse
podcast number 95 i am dr brett
weinstein this is dr heather heing
we are your dark horses and chiefs no
that doesn't work sorry i i thought it
did and then it turned out that it
didn't it doesn't yeah it doesn't work
right yeah
um today we are going to be talking
about culture and consciousness uh that
is the subject of the penultimate
chapter of our forthcoming book a
hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century and we have been walking through
these chapters a little bit
every week in on the run up to the
publication date which is now only a
week and a half away so
we're going to be talking about
collective joy and dancing in the
streets and taboo and the sacred and the
shamanistic and hallucinogens a little
bit and hell yeah this is where the
rubber meets the road is it
it's one of the places that the rubber
meets the road i'm i'm not sure that i'm
not even sure what it is if that's a
that's a metaphor here i'm not sure that
applies but maybe all right no i'm
pretty sure metaphorically we're right
there although i think you may have just
given someone a very bad trip frankly
well yeah i hope they were sitting down
they're lying down
okay so we're going to be spending our
our time with you on that today and then
we'll do the q a afterwards where um you
know all all topics are possible but we
never get to all the questions and we
and we pick and choose the questions
that you send in
uh you can write in questions at
darkhorsesubmissions.com which again
we'll get to
um we'll do this for an hour hour and a
half um take a 15-minute break or so and
then come back
for an hour or so of q a afterwards we
are streaming on both youtube and on
odyssey the chat is live on odyssey
it is not live on youtube just because
keeping track of two chats was a little
much for our awesome moderators
um consider joining our patreons to help
support us especially since we are still
demonetized here on youtube um brett had
an amazing conversation this morning
with one of his patreon groups and
you'll be having another one tomorrow
yes it was an excellent conversation
thank you for it guys excellent for
those of you watching um as i guess at
the moment everyone who's paying
attention right now is watching you just
saw the back of fairfax's head so we
will be having occasional cameos from
from fairfax the cat hopefully
um
goliath t-shirts and other and other
dark horse wares are available at
store.darkhorsepodcast.org
please consider coming over to
naturalselections.substance.com
to see
weekly writings from me this week i was
writing about
flow and various um manifestations of
how it is that humans find flow and
therefore meaning
and uh today we have before we get into
the
bulk of the show two ads for you
first we have all form
this week's show is sponsored by all
form and also by expressvpn but first
all forum is a company that is making
absolutely terrific sofas what makes it
terrific well you can customize your
size layout materials easily and that
comes at a fraction of the cost of
traditional sofas pick your fabric color
shape to fit your home and needs
perfectly they do arm chairs and love
seats all the way up to an eight seat
sectional you can start small and buy
more seats later on without needing to
get a whole new sofa
all form sofas are also delivered
directly to your home shipping is free
they're delivered fast just three to
seven days and you can assemble it
yourself
we've got a beautiful sectional all-form
sofa in whiskey leather
it's soft and supple and not cold and
many people with leather furniture will
recognize that often it's cold and what
seemed wonderful at some time of the
year did not seem wonderful later and
now we have not had the sofa in the
winter yet but it feels so warm that it
feels like it's going to be inviting
even when it's cold outside the four of
us and the dog and and the cats often
pile on it um to watch movies uh some
evenings it looks beautiful it's very
inviting comfortable
and we just we really enjoy it a lot and
if you order one don't like it they've
got a 100-day
they've got a 100-day full refund policy
so you can say no thank you for whatever
reason and they'll come and pick it up
for free and they also offer a forever
warranty
so to find your perfect sofa check out
allform.com
darkhorse
and uh you will get 20 off all of your
order um off all of your orders for
listeners to um to darkhorse wow
allform.com
darkhorse and i am out
excellent well um i will see if i can uh
improve improve on that right
here's something i did not know about
expressvpn even though i have been using
it which is that netflix actually
restricts what shows you can watch based
on your location and if you use
expressvpn you can therefore watch shows
that are available in other locations
that you don't have access to at your
home location so for example you can
look at pulp fiction on canadian netflix
you can watch modern family on uk
netflix you can watch spirited away on
australian netflix and so on
so how does this happen expressvpn
unblocks the content by changing your
apparent online location it adjusts your
isp they have almost 100 different
server locations
and this works with many other streaming
services as well i personally have
watched bbc documentaries that are not
accessible outside of the uk by
switching my location so that it appears
that i am in the uk and you can do this
without even faking the access i was
just gonna ask you're not even having to
affect the accent you do not although
that can be fun i do it anyway right of
course you know
first but the fact is you don't have to
fake the accent and you can still watch
everything on the bbc which is great so
why should you choose expressvpn when
there are many vpns available one
blazing fast speeds they really are fast
because they have all of these locations
and somehow the interrelationship
between them has been well optimized so
you will barely notice that anything
different is happening except that from
the point of view of your isp and others
who might watch your behavior they can't
tell who you are because you've been
pooled with other users it is compatible
with all of your devices it's compatible
with your phones laptops media consoles
smart tvs
and it encrypts your data
so you really are hidden and your data
won't be sold to people who aggregate
such things to build a model of you that
they will then use to exploit your own
psychology against you or whatever it is
that they do so
uh for instance
four examples model your psychology and
sell you things you don't need
convince you of things that aren't true
all right so be smart stop paying full
price for streaming services only to get
a small fraction of their content get
your money's worth at expressvpn.com
darkhorse don't forget to use our link
at expressvpn e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n
dot-com slash darkhorse to get an extra
three months of expressvpn for free
[Music]
the screen or something such that it is
sending a really bad hdmi signal i need
one of your hdmi you know connections um
are we still are we still streaming
you're live
we are live we are having a technical
difficulty hey zach wiggle the cable
i've done that i need
so what what is it that you need some
your monitoring screen that has password
messaging
you continue on i think i know how to
fix it um maybe maybe i should
begin by reading an excerpt since i
honestly have no idea what it is that
zack is asking for from us i don't i'm
not currently in the possession of
cables therefore i have no cables to
offer
um
while
again
while we are working on our technical
problems um i am going to read
one of three excerpts this week from
we have it here we actually just
yesterday got a copy of the actual book
in hand a hundred gatherers guide to the
21st century
evolution and the challenges of modern
life and man this just feels really
really good to have this after
you know depending on how you count
months of waiting years of waiting well
over a decade in the making so like we
said
the penultimate chapter of the book is
culture and consciousness
and we are going to share
three excerpts
uh from it today and still you know i
basically wanted to read all of it but
we're not we're not doing that uh so let
us begin
let us begin with definitions
these will not precisely match others
definitions but it is important on this
topic to have stated what we are talking
about
for our purposes culture we define as
beliefs and practices that are shared
and passed between members of a
population
these beliefs are often literally false
metaphorically true
implying that they result in increased
fitness if one acts as if they are true
despite the fact that they are either
inaccurate or unfalsifiable
culture is a special mode of
transmission because it can be passed
horizontally rendering cultural
evolution immensely faster and more
nimble than genetic evolution
this also renders culture noisy in the
short term before new ideas have endured
the test of time
long-standing features of culture by
contrast constitute an efficient
packaging of proven patterns culture can
spread horizontally but its
consequential parts are ultimately
passed vertically from generation to
generation culture is received wisdom
generally handed to you by ancestors and
officially transmitted
consciousness we define as we laid out
in the very first chapter of the book as
that portion of cognition that is newly
packaged for exchange meaning that
conscious thoughts are ones that could
be delivered if someone asked you what
you were thinking about it is emergent
cognition where innovation and rapid
refinement occur
conscious thoughts may never be conveyed
but they can be and the most important
and the most important ones are as
consciousness is most fundamentally a
collective process in which many
individuals pool insights and skills to
discover what was previously not
understood
the products of consciousness are if
they prove useful ultimately packaged
into highly trans transmissible culture
we have said before in the book that the
human niche is niche switching more
specifically we argue that the human
niche is to move between the paired
inverse modes of culture and
consciousness
as an example let us consider the nez
pierce people who have lived in the
pacific northwest for many thousands of
years
since they arrived they have inhabited a
rich land and they now have
well-established cultural rules that
keep them safe and thriving their diet
has long included bulbs the storage
organs of plants which do not want to be
eaten
on these lands where the nespers came to
live both camus with highly nutritious
bulbs and death camus with bulbs that
are toxic grow
when not in flower these bulbs are
incredibly difficult to tell apart
the nez pierce may not have been the
first on this land but someone was and
those first people could not benefit
from names that would make the danger
clear
yet they learned the distinction
presumably through trial and error it
was likely a messy tragic process
by the 19th century however when
spaniards were documenting what they saw
among the nez pierce the system of
distinguishing nutritious chemists from
their deadly relatives was nearly
perfect
this is culture
when humans are exploiting a
well-understood opportunity like 19th
century nez pierce distinguishing camas
from death camus culture is king
but when novelty renders ancestral
wisdom inadequate as it was as it was
for the more ancient ancestral nazi
pearce upon arrival in the pacific
northwest we need to shift to
consciousness
through parallel processing of multiple
human minds our consciousness can become
collective and we can solve problems
that either we could solve as
individuals nor ancestors could have
even imagined
but another way
in times of stability when inherited
wisdom allows individuals to prosper and
spread across relatively homogeneous
landscapes culture reigns
but in times of expansion into new
frontiers when innovation and
interpretation and communication of new
ideas are critical
consciousness reigns
that said novel levels of novelty such
as we are experiencing now are a special
danger this means that what is needed
today and urgently is a call to
consciousness on a scale that we have
not seen before
so that's our first excerpt for today
and we are back we are back in business
here tech wise
well let's treat it as if it works and
if not we will resort to
other cameras indeed um yeah so i'm
really excited that this model is in the
world we have talked about it at least
once publicly before we talked about it
on a um a discussion with robbie george
a talk for princeton in the spring of
last year
but i do think that humans are
as
my advisor dick alexander famously said
the uniquely unique species and the
question really is what is it about
humans that allows us to be uniquely
unique and i believe that this model is
a strong contributor to the difference
so
uh just to flesh it out a little bit
yeah um
people will recognize that when we say
you know something like uh
what does what is a tufted tit mouse
right we were talking about a particular
species and as people remarkably do
occasionally say to us well sure yes i
mean why wouldn't you what is it tough
to do what is this after titmouse we're
not going to answer that question here
today tufted tit mouse is just a
stand-in for
uh any species and in general if you ask
what a species is it comes with a
description of a niche each species has
some set of things that it does and it
can be a very broad generalist niche you
know a a raccoon has a very generous
niche it does a lot of different things
a little poorly mountain lion is a
little different mountain lion
uh different populations will exploit
different kinds of prey and so depending
upon the habitat they may look very
different um but for human beings it's
very hard to specify what the niche is
because if you look at all of the
various things that people do
it's tremendously variable and if you
look at all of the things that people
have done while we have been fully
modern people it's even more variable
it's even more variable in some ways in
many ways we're getting we're becoming a
more homogeneous species right in some
ways we are becoming more homogeneous
but
obviously if a modern human that is to
say the physical being can be teleported
into any one of those niches and can
function well so long as it develops
there and picks up
the correct programming to to function
that suggests something very bizarre
about us which is that we are somehow a
creature that upgrades our own software
and that does not mean
improves it it means radically swaps out
one set of software at the point that
you change what it is that you're eating
and what sorts of hostile forces you're
facing switches out the software uh
on mass in order to replace it with a
software package that has been
bootstrapped for the new local
circumstances
and is an amazing capacity so
how the hell do we do it how do we do it
and um dick alexander had a different um
somewhat different although not in
conflict with i would say this model of
um oscillating forces oscillating
selective forces right that there were
that we were striving against
effectively ecology dart so-called
darwin's hostile forces um things like
you know weather and climate and
predators and parasites um and obviously
we still have to contend with those
things there are you know those things
are in the news now right um and then
there was also the effectively social
competition um that we
became our biggest competitors we became
our our most dominant competitor and so
sorry we became our own most our own
most dominant so yeah these things
aren't in conflict at all and in fact so
that's dick's model and then our model
is is this culture and consciousness but
i should just say dick's model has to
precede ours because stick's model is
really an explanation for why the human
brain got so disproportionately large
and it had to do with an arms race
between human lineages that caused
lineages that could out-think their
competitors to win and basically we all
inherited this greatly and char
enlarged thinking apparatus but
not only is it an enlarged thinking
apparatus it is a thinking apparatus
that is not heavily pre-programmed it is
somewhat pre-programmed we are not
playing slates but it is not fully
pre-programmed and that means there is
room
to swap in a an agriculturalist
high-altitude agriculturalist program if
you're you know farming corn in the
andes
uh or you could swap in a marine mammal
hunting program if you were uh you know
hunting whales in the arctic and that's
a radically different way of being and
it requires very different programming
exactly and so you know we we are and as
we say in the book we are not blank
slates but we are of all the species on
the planet the blankest slates and we
are blanker even than um our two closest
extant relatives that is the two species
on the planet to which we are most
closely related
we are equally related to chimps and
bonobos and they are they are
interestingly quite different from one
another
but you i don't think it's ever been
tried but a prediction behind which i
would stand and put a lot of money is
that if you try to cross foster a bonobo
with a chimp family or a chimp with a
bonobo family uh the chimpyness will
persist in the chimp raised with bonobos
and the bonobonus
manoa wishness will persist in the
bonobo race with chimps whereas
if you cross foster
any human being in any other human
culture so long as you start at infancy
basically all of the things of that
of the family in which the baby has been
cross-fostered will come on board
obviously melanin isn't going to change
but and you know facial shape
although you know even even some things
like face shape will change as a result
of diet as we've been as we've talked
about diet and uh different you know you
could at least have different facial
expressions obviously there's huge
exposures
but the language will be different and
the cultural the you know the memes and
the expressions and the expectations
and um therefore to some degree the
periodicity and the timing of events
uh you know you know babies who are
raised with a lot of love but in very
restrained physical situations
among the tajik for instance which we
talked about a couple weeks ago um walk
really light compared to to weird babies
you know
western educated industrialized rich
democratic society bred weird babies uh
whereas some babies in kenya where it's
you know the encouragement is to move a
lot very early they walk earlier and you
know you could take a tagic baby and
raise it in that kenyan village and and
that tajik baby would walk earlier this
is not in the genetic layer it's in the
software it's in the software layer and
it is
both the fact of the software layer
which you know a lot of this will be
familiar in one regard or another to
people who've been
watching and listening to us but the
software layer
is every bit as biological it is a
different way of transmitting
information it is transmitted outside of
the genome but it is not less biological
and we argue
i think persuasively in the book that it
is
subject to the objectives of the genome
and so the question is how does a genome
that is trying to get into the future
and doesn't really care about how it
doesn't care about in what form or
through what behaviors upgrade its
software program so that it can take
advantage of whatever opportunities it
encounters along the way and so we
argue for this oscillating
uh set of modes one which you use when
you figured out how to behave in a
particular habitat and one which you use
when you have to figure out how to
behave in a new habitat whether that's
because your old habitat changed or
because you've moved or because you live
at the edge of a habitat where your
ancestral population developed its
insight and it is this ability which
you know the key thing is that human
beings can do something that no other
creature can do we can
actually faithfully transmit an abstract
idea across open air from one mind to
another and that allows us to do
something that no other creature can do
which is to pool insight and get an
emergent conclusion that is superior to
the sum of the individual conclusions
that different uh different people would
have if forced to to calculate
independently so let's just for stall an
objection i see which is that there are
at least proto-linguistic things
proto-linguistic communications in some
other organisms in which information is
being conveyed but in no other species
is information being conveyed with the
level of both accuracy and precision um
that that we can convey it you know
language is several steps beyond what
anyone else has and so
uh you know when we were in in college i
remember learning about um actually
cheney and safebarth's early work with
uh poised vervets i think it's vervet
monkeys
who have
three different vocalizations for the
three broad types of predators that they
are at risk from so they have a
different vocalization for an aerial
predator and this to say a predatory
bird that might be coming or
a terrestrial basically a mammal like a
big cat
and then also for snakes
and you know snakes snakes and cats
which are both are both a risk for
fervent monkeys come differently they
can move differently they really do
require a different kind of response if
you are going to maximize the likelihood
that you escape from it and so you know
they have
three very different vocalizations
suggesting
an understanding of their environment
that is rich and um and involved and
detailed and accurate and they can
convey that that information
but they don't seem to
be conveying
much beyond this thing is here you know
danger of one of three sorts yeah it is
a it is a
pre-existing agreement on the meaning of
an arbitrary signal
which is very different from an
abstraction and just if you haven't been
through the logic before the fact that
one can say something that one can be
reasonably sure is a
novel right if i say
potato bearing conifer right probably
that's not a useful enough thought that
anyone will have bothered to try it out
but if i say it and then i was to ask
you to draw a picture we could establish
that i had successfully conveyed it over
open air because you'd draw a you know a
pine tree with a potato growing off it
or something like that right
that i'm not sure at what end but i but
i can do it to no useful and accept that
we have established that in fact we are
not kidding ourselves that we are
transmitting abstract thoughts between
our minds that we are actually
succeeding in doing i mean well and not
and not just transmitting right so you
know the and this is this is one of the
um frequent concerns about the you know
the many ape language studies that have
that have gone on where um many apes
seem to be able to demonstrate receptive
language and to be able to some degree
to use combinatorics to convey somewhat
new ideas
but
that you know that second thing is what
is often called into question the idea
that you can understand that that you
know another species of ape as we are uh
could understand language and you know
of course they're working at a
disadvantage not just linguistic um but
uh but because we are you know we're
framing things in in the world that
makes the most sense to us they're
working with the handicap that we have
handed to them assuming that they they
are like us and of course they are in
many ways but they will not be in some
others um but you know how capable are
they actually of innovating new
combinations with the pieces that we
have handed them
unclear
and certainly not as capable as we are
right right by far not there is a famous
example i mean and the problem is any
single example could be explained
as dumb luck but
i think the example is from coco the
gorilla who knew a
symbol for bird and knew a symbol for
water and described duck as water bird
right that suggests the combinatorics
but it doesn't nail it down but in our
case the point is transmitting an
abstract idea is the first step to
something that is really the whole point
of the exercise
if i can transmit an abstract idea about
a problem i have seen or a solution i
have imagined and then you can run it
through your separate mind with your
separate skills and without my blind
spots then we can recombine what we have
both come up with and that's where the
emergent value comes from and that i
mean that also
reveals that the the first individual to
be expressing a new idea
maybe doesn't need this but it will be
helped and there will be a greater
chance that they will
want make the attempt to convey
something in the first place if they
have theory of mind so i would say
theory of mind which we know to be
already present in apes and and baboons
which are not apes but our older world
monkeys
um to to a large degree if you know if
if you don't have theory of mind
and you therefore imagine that
everything else sees the world exactly
as you do to what end conveying new
things right the fact that you have an
idea um in your head may feel like okay
so i assume she knows that as well so
theory of mine would seem to be a sort
of implicit base layer as well well
yeah i mean at some level i think even a
shared language makes theory of mind so
utterly inherent
right
um
if i'm talking to you and i say uh you
know
grocery store
right i know exactly what you put
together maybe i can't paint the ex the
identical picture but whether you
imagine a you know a bodega or a
supermarket it doesn't matter i know
that it lands in a certain quadrant and
if i speak to somebody who speaks
mandarin and i say you know grocery
store
i don't know that they pick up anything
right because i just don't know whether
that word will even register as a
familiar one now maybe it does maybe
that's one of the words that is crossed
over but right but the point is theory
of mind
a shared language is a uh almost
impossibly complex shared theory of mind
inherently indeed
and uh and anyway it creates the basis
for
um
for
overcoming obstacles extremely rapidly
right think about what evolution has to
overcome if it functions at a genetic
level in order to innovate the tools
necessary to hunt a new kind of prey
right unless it's very like an old kind
of prey it's going to take a long time
for the program to be modified at a
genetic level whereas it can be modified
in hours if people get into conversation
about
here's what we're doing here's why it
doesn't work and here's what we might do
that would fix it right that's a very
rich conversation and basically it turns
evolution
onto an extreme form of fast forward
which is the reason that human beings
don't have a niche is that we're
actually better off without one because
it means if we happen onto a niche we
can figure out what to do with it
so we're constantly
happening upon new niches through
spatial exploration and creating new
niches through technological innovation
and the like and therefore over time
we find new niches as well so you know
and and you already invoked this but you
know traveling across space and time we
are able to deal with the new niches
that we are either finding ourselves in
or creating for ourselves better than
any other species on the planet but not
quite good enough to deal with
the rapid change that we are creating on
the planet today i think this is a good
segue to the next very short excerpt
we're skipping over consciousness and
other animals and going to innovation at
the margins of the ancestors wisdom this
again from a hunter-gatherer's guide to
the 21st century
during the peopling of the new world
when was relying on consciousness more
effective than relying on culture under
what circumstances are cultural rules
more trustworthy
as the nez perce or their ancestors
moved into the range of camas and death
camus they were looking for food in an
increasingly unfamiliar landscape the
staples they had come to know were their
cultural standbys as those familiar
foods became harder to source innovation
became ever more necessary they were
reaching the limits of their ancestors
wisdom and confronting a puzzle for
which the best tool was consciousness
as the people move across space it is
relatively easy to notice as the
ancestor's wisdom becomes less
applicable as a people move through time
however as we all do elders may not
recognize their wisdom becoming out of
date the young see it it is no accident
that those who are coming of age in
times of change push boundaries and that
language and norms change somewhat with
each generation
throughout history the ancestors wisdom
has generally remained relevant long
enough for new generations to get their
footing to know what needs to be pushed
against as a people move through time
that is changing extremely rapidly
however as our world is now it is more
difficult to know what to do with the
increasing irrelevancy of the ancestors
wisdom and with what to replace it
the margins of the ancestors wisdom are
rarely hard and fast at those margins
wherever they are it is time to niche
switch
consider three broad contexts in which
humans have learned and innovated in
times past
the first is the utterly new idea the
idea that springs to mind often unbidden
and without explanation
this was the territory that the first
mayan mesopotamian and chinese people
were in when they innovated farming
similarly the innovation of the wheel
metallurgy and pottery before those
things existed nobody knew they were
possible
the second context in which innovation
occurs is when you know that something
is possible on the basis that it's been
done before but you have no idea how to
make it happen
the wright brothers saw flight in other
organisms and felt confident that it
could be accomplished by machine
third and finally you might have
instruction you know what you're
shooting for and have someone or some
set of rules or instructions telling you
how
between school and youtube we often
conflate this third kind of learning for
the only kind of learning that is
possible
the third type of learning is the most
cultural it is the learning of perceived
wisdom in contrast humans are at our
most conscious and therefore are most
innovative in the first two contexts
when the status quo when the status quo
is no longer sufficient we must seek to
innovate to push beyond how it's always
been done
the status quo is an inherent tension
the status quo is in inherent tension
with our unique insights those ideas
that we have deep at night are often
syntheses reflecting the pulling
together of common threads into uncommon
meaning
so these three contexts and you know
this
everything this book does tie together
as as diverse and broad as the book is
but you're talking about the three
broadly three different ways that humans
can learn
and just making explicit that school and
now youtube and many people will be
surprised to find us lumping youtube
with school but youtube and school
especially the youtube videos that
provide direct instruction for you know
how to do a thing
are a very explicit
modern
cultural
mode of conveying information
that allows for very little freedom and
innovation and consciousness
well actually you know i think it's
important to realize that school is
necessary in some sense but it is
inherently if done right a supplement to
the majority of learning which is not
best done
in school so for example and
i think the example that makes this
clearest is
nobody needs to put you in school
to teach you how to talk
right teaching
teaching you how to talk is something
that happens automatically if you're if
your ears and your mind are healthy at
birth we can't even stop you from
learning to talk you'll pick it up out
of the air and very probably your
parents
are programmed to be unable to resist
the things that will help you do it like
babbling back at a child it's very hard
not to babble back at a child what you
heard them say right now think about it
the way you sound to yourself inside
your head is very different from what
other people hear so how useful is it to
have somebody tell you oh here's what i
heard you just say right it's a feedback
right so anyway the point is
yeah it's uh it's a way to allow the
child to error correct right exactly
it's not mockery it's it's a a root into
i mean it's it is it is training theory
of mind it is it is it again requires
theory of mind i heard you say this i
heard you say this right and oh my god
it meant this to me you said ball now
maybe i didn't mean to say ball but if
you then break out a ball and you're all
excited i get the sense that this object
and what i just said and your reaction
are all somehow tied together maybe i'll
try to trigger that cool thing again you
know
so um anyway we don't have to put you in
school to teach you to talk right in
fact or walk right well right because
again the parent offspring system is
built to to make this happen we do need
to put you in school or something very
like it at least we need formal training
to teach you to read and write
and the reason for this is pretty
obvious at least in retrospect it's that
speaking are very very ancient they're
going to go back at least several
hundred thousand years and more likely a
million or more what what are speaking
oh um reading writing what
speaking r speaking r yeah okay speaking
r um
reading and writing go back a maximum of
something like 8 000 years and for most
people they would have been a non-issue
until very late like the recent several
hundred years and so the point is
evolution hasn't had the chance to build
the mechanism that you automatically
acquire this just by looking at the
symbols in your world so i mean i
we we have this argument in the book and
i agree with it and yet you know maybe
for the first time hearing you talk
about it here
i had this thought of like
i don't know how much formal schooling i
needed um i was you know i was so driven
to the written world and you know you
and i have such different brains in this
regard i was so i i talked late you know
more completely rather than in single
words and i read early and that was just
where i was driven to go and sure i had
the same kind of parental feedback as
you were talking about with regard to
walking and talking but that happened um
before school and yeah you know for many
for many people it it is a matter of
direct instruction although frankly so
much of how direct instruction takes
place is destructive of the desire to
keep learning right i'm not arguing that
school itself is necessary but the
formalism of this is an alphabet right
these are the letters in it this is the
sequence in which they come these are
the yeah i'm not i'm actually i'm not
sure like i think i think that that is
that is the way it is taught and that's
not the way that some of us learned it
we sort of we were walking around doing
you know sort of picking symbols out of
our universe going like oh that i see
that other people look at that and
they're making meaning from it just like
you're talking about with regard to um
spoken language i believe the motivation
would be there but i don't believe that
you would the amount of arbitrariness in
an alphabet and the way
alphabetic symbols are put together into
words and at least in english right but
the variation of the pronunciation of
those
phonemes and all of that you need
somebody to be the one to clue you into
the underlying arbitrary associations
before you can begin to put them
together with the stuff that you already
have on board which is the spoken word
right so you know that there is a word
for duck right and then the arbitrary
symbols have sounds and then those
sounds come together and it's like ah
that's the overarching symbol for duck i
meant this this is interesting i
actually i really do think you have a
model in your head that's not a match
for what some of us experience i don't
you know the the idea of like pieces
that come together it's like not
necessarily i don't i don't think this
is the place to get mired down but i i
do think that um
that
those of us who are very driven to and
seek out and always want to have sort of
written word in front of us are probably
likely and at least anecdotally in my
case we're not people who were doing
like you know phoneme let's see what it
sounds like when you put it together it
was much more like and we're in and
we're doing like yeah but
i i it's interesting to me that we have
a disagreement here you have to be able
to say
daddy what's this symbol right oh that's
a d right in order to get to the word in
order to get to the meaning of the word
and so the idea i think what
the upshot of what you're arguing is
that some people would learn to read
even if nobody clued them into the
meaning of
the arbitrary symbols in the alphabet
and i don't i don't believe that anybody
would pick it up from exposure to those
things
that effectively literacy requires
formalism
whereas the ability to speak does not
um and it's you know it's a little bit
like um
you know it's almost exactly like
reading music too right musicality does
not require reading music but if you're
going to go
into if you're going to be musically
literate in that same sense then
somebody has to clue you into the schema
in order to to pick it up but anyway
well certainly i mean that that that is
a better match for my experience with
with music having been sort of
introduced to both playing music and
reading music both very young and almost
simultaneously and they were you know
they're both highly formalized processes
um but anyway the the point is
we
a a hunter-gatherer child does not go to
school and it does not mean that they
are uneducated it means that they are
built such that their environment
educates them without the need for the
formalism and the farther you get from
an environment that educates you
naturally i mean even think about
walking down the street right the fact
that there is a line at the edge of the
sidewalk where things go from very safe
to extremely dangerous that's a very
arbitrary odd thing and you're not so it
sounds like you're talking about a line
drawn and sometimes it is but really
you're talking about a uh
a physical feature of the universe that
is a border um called the curb yeah it
can be either but i think the point is
the six inch drop at the curb does not
begin to tell you about the hazard that
starts there it's a tall curb
i think that's a really tall curb yeah
okay i don't know i mean
in our in our neighborhood there are
lots of places where there isn't even a
curb but just the idea that you're
paying attention to some
line and that the you know
the forces generated on one side of that
line are so many thousands of times
greater than the forces generated on the
other side that it's a whole different
model that applies
right that's a that's a kind of of you
know that's not the natural world being
logically deducible that's arbitrary
stuff right and you know some formalism
is necessary in all those cases
yeah um but
uh so anyway so yeah school is necessary
but it's a supplement and we tend to as
you were reading we tend to think of
school as the way in which learning is
done and in fact this becomes perfectly
absurd if you if you think about
watching
uh an expert rock climber right
and you think about
learning how it is that they ascend
something like el capitan
you can know a hell of a lot about how
you climb el capitan without knowing the
first thing about
doing it learn better rock climbing
right learn better yeah you can learn
all sorts of things right now just i
don't remember who said it but you know
this this famous advice to people trying
to learn tennis from tennis pro you know
play better tennis right where in fact
what you really need is somebody
who plays better tennis than you to keep
returning the ball and putting it at
different corners challenging you in
unexpected ways right you don't you
don't learn when you're super
comfortable you're not going to learn
maximally when you're super comfortable
and frankly a lot of modern schooling as
much as it feels ridiculous and deeply
uncomfortable to people is effectively a
a dulling experience like we're just
gonna like you can sit down you don't
have to move too much you don't have to
go outside of your expected bounds you
know you know when you sit here you're
gonna today it's history and you know
that's not where you're gonna learn the
most you're gonna learn the most it's
like oh we're out you know we're up
playing frisbee and now we're gonna now
we're gonna start talking about history
or you know or we're in the rain forest
and we're gonna start talking about the
history of you know the the rubber
industry in the amazon or whatever it is
this is gonna come it the lessons that
come at the unexpected moments and and
throw you
are are where you are likely to learn
the most yeah absolutely
so um we do have i do want to share one
more excerpt from
from the book but i also wanted to
because this chapter is about this
tension between culture and
consciousness we've talked about
and uh we also talk about and i think
this is maybe in the final excerpt um
that being analogous to that the tension
between the sacred and the shamanistic
the sacred being sort of a reification
of the orthodoxy of the perceived wisdom
of therefore the culture and the
shamanistic being
an analogy for that which is chaotic
that which is unexpected that which is
where innovation happens most of which
is going to be probably useless some of
which might even be dangerous but that's
where the innovation is going to happen
it's it's by analogy to what goes on in
the genome where some things are
extremely resistant to mutation and
therefore very slow to change and
there's a very good reason that you
would do that there's certain things
that if you upend them cancel the whole
project and so they get special
protection from change so sacred in
cultural space is that which is heavily
protected from change because uh change
tends to be very disruptive and then
there are other things that are prone to
change things like the immune system
needs to be able to update its model of
uh hazards
you know even within a lifetime and so
there's
sort of uh overdrive for uh mutation and
so our point is that you've got these
two things both within you know we we
deliberately describe them in this
uh religious framework but the idea is
it's not that religion
is this stodgy force religion has both
of these components because of course
religions are compendiums of
wisdom that lineages need and so they
need in order to be compendiums of
wisdom they have to be able to bootstrap
new wisdom how do you do that well it
starts out in the shamanistic and then
that which works gets driven into the
sacred and gets protected
from change and you know it's not that
the sacred doesn't change but the point
is it changes slowly because because of
the hazard of unintended consequences
yeah
so i want um to read an excerpt from a
different book um but first just to talk
about exactly what you were where you
were just going
um
the the tension within society between
the sacred and the shamanistic and
sometimes sometimes it's in within a
religion and sometimes it's as a
religion is trying to move in and
displace the old ways so i'm reminded
of you know
actually a description of it's a it's a
fantasy novel that i recently reread but
it describes some accuracies from from
history the mists of avalon which is a
sort of a women's a retelling of
arthurian legend from the perspective of
the women involved
and it portrays the tension between the
old ways like the druids and the and the
fairies and such and the new ways the
christians and um and portrays arthur as
exactly at this nexus between them you
know feeling this tension feeling the
value and the old and also
the pull of the new and frankly the
order of the new the you know the the
organization of the new and everything
that organization promises and also
the the chaos and the unexpected and the
passion and the fury of the old right so
you know for all of us we can imagine we
can recognize that there is tension
between
between order and chaos right
and similarly in it was episode 67 on
february 13th of this year we talked
about carnival
which is um
in in the us
um it manifests as mardi gras but um
we have we have attended uh we've
attended a carnival together and i've
been at a couple more in latin america
and
um we spoke some about what a former
professor of mine who works on carnival
in the atlantic coast of brazil
um describes as some of the really
necessary parts of this you know this
these three is it three or four i can't
remember three or four days
of just
just freedom before the 40 days of
very
um
very careful attention to your religion
of lent before before good friday and
then easter
and so my professor dan linger
anthropology professor at uc santa cruz
talked about symbolic reversals of power
being important in carnival
and um you know that can manifest as
men dressing up as women and vice versa
and
young people acting as if they're old
and have power and employers acting as
employees and vice versa and of course
in the old days that could even
that even manifested um with regard to
slave relationships so you know during
carnival sort of all of the expected
rules were on hold like everyone knew
that they were coming back but they were
on hold for a little bit so it's a
little bit analogous to what we were
talking about with respect to babbling
back at a baby yeah right interesting if
you from the other side of the power
relationship say yeah here's what that's
like yeah that's what that seems to be
like um here's how it seems like you're
acting when you do this right yeah i'm
also uh
i don't know how new a thought it is but
you know one of the things at the
carnival that we experienced in ecuador
in 2016 yeah um
was you know one of the
sort of games that gets played has to do
with this canned foam that people are
shooting at each other yes
right exactly um and i was remembering
we may have even showed a picture of it
this uh police
marching band
uh being sprayed with foam by onlookers
and the thing is it's actually you know
if in the u.s context you know the
tension between police and others is
such that it's almost hard to imagine
such a thing but the idea that you know
this band is just playing on as people
that you know
they would have had a very different
power relationship with under any other
circumstances were freed in some very
non-lethal way
to uh you know to blow off steam at them
how much better are those relations
between uh one party and the next when
there is this sort of
recurring pressure relief it does
suggest that we could all use some
carnival some regular you know knowing
that it's coming being able to prepare
for it knowing that it's finite knowing
that it will end
uh but that i think
some of what happened last summer in the
u.s and to some degree large cities
around the world with prior to the
protests that became riots
um was as we said then in response to
lockdowns but it was in part precisely a
response not just to lockdowns of uh you
know being away from one another but
there were no concerts there were no
festivals there you know the bars were
closed and
it's easy to dismiss such things
festivals and concerts and bars and you
know large parties
as unimportant but they're not they're
not they are necessary for humans and
you know different people enjoy them
differently some people have none of
them in their lives and and do just fine
and some of them live for these things
and maybe could do with a little bit
less and would be more productive but um
the idea that they are frivolous and can
just be dismissed with uh with no cost
is is absurd so um
there are symbolic reversals of power in
carnival there are rituals of rebellion
and critiques of the status quo and
inviting in of the liminal so
specifically this professor of mine 20
almost 30 years ago was talking about
working at the edge of consciousness
specifically at carnival that this is a
place for conscious exploration of of
and and and play and i'm reminded of
that too in this um terrific book this
is a 2006 book by barbara aaron reich
dancing in the streets i don't even know
where my camera is um there we go
dancing in the streets a history of
collective joy which is a book that i
read um actually as part of one of the
programs i taught the linguist i was
teaching with recommended it and we we
read this and i have just a short
section
uh from
chapter two that she's called
civilization and backlash to share
almost as soon as ecstatic rituals
appear in the historical that is written
record a note of ambivalence enters into
the story a suggestion of social tension
surrounding these rituals and even
violent hostility towards their
participants
euripides play the bakke for example
both records these tensions and
expresses what seems to be a tormented
ambivalence on the part of the
playwright
in the play pentheus the king of thebes
greets the god with derision and
determines to suppress him by force go
at once to the electron gate he commands
his officers tell all my men who bear
shields heavier light all who ride fast
horses or twang the bowstring to meet me
there in readiness for an assault on the
bakke this is all this is past all
bearing if we are to let women so defy
us
at first the play seems to take the god
side mocking the uptight pentheus and
showing the community elders piously
joining the men adds in their revelry
after all if the beautiful young
stranger is indeed a god it is incumbent
on good citizens to observe his rights
but things end badly for both sides
pentheus is killed and dismembered by
his own mother who and her god-given
ecstasy mistakes him for a lion we've
all been there
the ambivalence and hostility that's
that was not aaron reich that was my
editorializing in case you guys were
wondering
um then to continue with aaron rank's
words
um
actually this is this is all fabulous so
i'm just going to skip to this paragraph
here
we have some evidence from a very
different part of the ancient world of
the dampening effect of civilization and
social hierarchy on traditional rituals
recent carbon 14 dating of an
archaeological site in oaxaca suggests
that the earliest residents who were
hunter-gatherers living about 9 000
years ago met on a cleared dance ground
for rituals that included the entire
community
later with the rise of agriculture
rituals appear to have been enacted
solely by initiates who were social
achievers or members of an elite and
most likely men
finally with the emergence of organized
and militarized states two thousand
years ago the archaeolo the
archaeologists deduced that quote many
important rituals were performed only by
trained full-time priests using
religious calendars and occupying
temples built by corvae labor
in the oaxacan case only a few thousand
years appear to have elapsed between the
archaic danced rituals of paleolithic
bands and their refinement into the
formal rituals of the civilized state
and i mean the whole the whole book i
recommend but it really is both an
exploration of um the history of
ecstasis of ecstasy of finding ecstasy
through movement through dance through
she doesn't go i think if i remember too
much into
the use of exogenous
substances although there's those are
certainly present in almost all of these
cases at least by some
um and
and the the orthodoxy the controlling
part of society that says actually no
you shan't do that because well you'll
be less productive and you know it the
the pushback comes with lots of words
and some of them are true and some of
them is just a cover story but um you
know you'll be more productive if you
don't do that
we're going to restrict that just to say
carnival
but
really it's about control and people
experiencing extasis experiencing these
kinds of you know hyper-conscious
perhaps entheogen
uh in inflamed states are hard to
control they're hard to predict and it's
hard to know what they're going to do
next and what they're going to think
next too well it's a
high noise high creativity
state and the point
noise isn't good noise in this case i'm
talking about statistical noise and i
guess the short version of this would be
in a complex system there are a huge
number of influences and you may be
interested in one particular parameter
and
everything else that affects it is noise
with respect to the change in that one
parameter so
there's lots of noise
in the cognition that comes along with
things like entheogens
and that is not a positive thing but it
is part and parcel of the process that
generates creativity in other words if
your thinking day-to-day
is high quality it is also
limited in order to be high quality and
low noise it has to bar possibilities
that could be but aren't worth
investigation and so
in sort of in one sense
it's like
cognitive carnival right you take some
period of time and you choose to reverse
the normal priority the normal
priorities in perceiving the world
accurately and behaving reasonably with
respect to it what if you suspend those
rules for a day and you say actually i'd
prefer to tune in to things that
ordinarily i would dismiss because some
small fraction of them are actually
useful and i can't see them because my
highly functioning mind blocks them from
me tune in explore cross boundaries
know that those kinds of explorations
within reason will be forgiven later
yeah it's a little bit yeah so that's
that's the thing is you don't want to
assume that it's insight because most of
it's nonsense right but
nor nor can you
you know if if you have murderous
instincts you're not allowed to act on
those like there will be repercussions
if you have rapey instincts no right but
so you know there are still
it's a it's a matter of pushing
boundaries and seeing where the
boundaries could be sometimes but are
still within the realm that we can all
get along with one another yeah or i
would say if you're the kind of person
who doesn't have those things
uh sufficiently locked down that you
can't be
sure they will not rear their ugly head
then that's not an experiment for you
right but if you are the kind of person
who can handle
uh
relaxing the mental controls that
usually keep madness at bay and you can
say well i would like to try madness for
a brief period of time and see if
anything comes of it then it is an
experiment with during and
i would also uh this may seem like a
weird segue it's a segue certainly to an
earlier chapter in the book but
we are faced with
very difficult challenges we ultra
moderns right hyper novelty has thrown
us for example
a puzzle about what to do
with um the relationships between the
sexes how to build a relationship when
the stuff that used to make
relationships coherent and necessary has
evaporated and how do you bootstrap the
new version of this
and
one thing that's true is when you are
trying to solve a problem that is
outside the range of the toolkit you've
got you have no choice but to engage a
higher mode of creativity right some way
or other you're going to have to
experiment beyond the comfortable and
one way that is available
is certainly uh to
you know i mean i i
i like better and better
huxley's
idea of the doors of perception because
maybe doors is a little too binary but
the idea that one can actually adjust
the permeability of consciousness
in order to see whether there are tools
that are nearby but not immediately
available to the normally regulated
conscious mind that's as useful in the
context of relationships as anywhere
else maybe even more useful and
the risk of saying too much
you and i had plenty of formative
experiences together
and you know how powerful is that to be
able to
uh
you know step out of the normal world
together with somebody and explore it's
really
uh an amazing tool no it's it's
completely extraordinary and um
yeah so one of the corrective lens items
from this chapter is consider engaging
with psychedelics carefully
if there is anything in you that is
curious
they are now legal in some places but
consider engaging them as the powerful
cognitive tools that they are not as a
form of recreation that doesn't mean you
can't have fun
and certainly um
you know we've had a lot of fun with
them uh and we've had some times that
were not fun and they were
um some more formative than others but
they were all impactful
in a way that is
impossible to describe it's it's maybe a
little bit analogous to the idea of
trying to talk trying to tell someone
what parenthood is like if you don't
have children like oh
it's a different kind of love well that
just that falls flat everyone knows that
that doesn't communicate that doesn't
convey it and yet
it's true right like the the parent's
love for a child is unlike anything else
and um uh you know an experience
with exogenous
uh hallucinogens or antigens that are
that are strong enough that you really
do have something
you know the language used as ego death
and i'm not sure i totally i totally
like that language but um
something strong enough such that you
lose
your desire to control your situation or
you lose
you know that you've just lost the
ability to do so and so you just
are there
uh is extraordinary with regard to
opening up you know as you say the doors
you know
the doors of perception and i will say i
don't know that i have a particular
excerpt to share but just another book
and we'll put these in the show notes as
well this book
on on drugs this book is on drugs um
and i don't even i think that's just it
there's no subtitle um by david lentz
and it's old at this point it's from
1995 which is you know it's fascinating
to read a book that is so
current and so modern that exists before
practically before the internet it's not
before the internet but certainly before
social media you know before even you
know 1998 before the dot-com bubble um
but you know his descriptions
he explores just so much of what it is
um
what what drugs are what they do
how drugs are described in society by
the orthodoxy as an uncivilizing
influence especially on children
and
you know he specifically if if memory
serves
talks about differences between what he
calls drugs of desire
um cocaine crack speed and drugs of
pleasure which is a strange word but by
by which he is including marijuana and
psychedelics and the the first category
being sort of
term
pretty uninteresting and
pretty much not valuable and i'm
editorializing here but if memory serves
has been a while since i've read this um
that's his conclusion as well whereas
the whereas the latter ones allow for
an opening of the doors of perception um
that um
that you can get other ways right like
you can people can get through
extreme sport
through some kinds of sexual engagement
through meditation through long
long you know periods alone without
talking to anyone like sweat lodge sweat
lodge and you know so a lot of the
things that are rituals from other
societies also do involve though some
additional exogenous molecule that
you're smoking or imbibing or whatever
it is right i mean you know in some
sense it's all endogenous you're
triggering circuits that are there and
you're triggering them in some way
that's novel enough that your conscious
mind gets to tune in on it or however it
works but um
but the real point is it's all
trade-offs right it's not like that
state doesn't come with downside in fact
that state is mostly downside you
couldn't run your life that way but
borrowing from it a little you know
diminishing returns being what they are
are you better off living your entire
life this side of that boundary or would
you know a tiny periodic adventure
across that boundary be worth a
tremendous amount in terms of what you
got to understand about
even what your own mind you know i mean
one of the things these sort of
inadvertent lessons uh that i got from
it is how little direct perception is
really just you
seeing the outside world it's color by
numbers and it's done very very well so
that you do get a real sense of where
the objects are and what they're made of
and all of that right
but you know
the simple fact of what happens when you
look in a mirror right tells you that
it's not just a report of where the
photons are going it's an interpolation
right and uh no i mean it and it brings
some of your disparate it can has the
potential to bring some of the disparate
parts of you into sort of awareness of
one another such that you can you can
become more light-hearted about your own
self and like observe yourself with with
with more mirth at some level i remember
an experience of you know knowing very
well that it was not incumbent upon me
to stand in a particular way to hold up
the building that i was leaning up
against but i had the very distinct
sense and in fact someone walked past me
i was like i'm holding up this building
you're welcome like you're welcome
you're safe um knowing that that's
patently untrue there's no way that this
building that existed before i ever
showed up and would continue to exist
after i left was in need of me
leaning up against the way i was but
something in my subjective experience as
helped by in that case ayahuasca
led me to believe even though i knew
logically it couldn't be the case that i
was necessary there at that moment and
you know what what's the lesson there i
don't know you know are are there are
there lessons to be had that are
explicit or that can become um conscious
and then you know usable from any one of
these stories probably not it's a little
bit like sharing dreams like probably
mostly the particular instances from
particular trips are just going to seem
you know they're going to fall flat for
people but
the fact is that you can you can learn
learn from the tensions that are
revealed
all right
this leads me to something that's going
to sound like a non-sequitur but i'm
sure it's the right place to go okay
okay you and i have been talking about
the predicament that young people find
themselves in with respect to finding a
partner and the fact that a lot of what
passes for
uh
current wisdom about this is actually
nonsense and some of it's actually just
downright pernicious i think i know
where you're going you want someone who
can hold up a building for you
and i've found just the person
as you have demonstrated i didn't get it
right did i no you you did not get it
right i want to interrupt all right we
have been talking about
the fact that in terms in the context of
mating and dating
humanity cannot go backwards right
there's not there are places in the past
where it worked but you couldn't restore
the conditions that made it coherent in
the first place you can't go back and we
can't stay here you know a free-for-all
in which there are no rules and we just
dismiss everything as you know
everything that involves any sort of
limit as stodgy that doesn't work at all
it makes people miserable it does not
result in
uh lasting partnerships that matter
so we have to design something new and
that designing something new
um
i so far believe and will argue is going
to involve people opting out of the
current wisdom but they have to opt into
something else where two people who
don't know each other who might be
interested in being together can say
yeah actually i subscribe to those rules
too because those rules make sense right
all right
i think
i think the name for the opt-out
movement
should be carbon dating
okay
carbon dating now the reason it should
be carbon dating
is because carbon
leads in all the right directions it's
the alternative to silicon dating which
hasn't worked out real well for people
sure right
carbon dating is the organic version
it's new it's up to date right but
carbon dating also involves things like
real experiences it could involve if
it's your sort of thing using entheogens
to change which you know sets of neurons
are prone to fire in a given
circumstance so experimentation could
generate the rules of carbon dating but
saying carbon dating seems to me like a
good shorthand for yeah i'm in on the
idea that we're trying to find some new
set of rules that make sense because no
rules isn't working out yeah
i like it i like it very much
um
okay let's um
let's go to our final excerpt from today
literally false metaphorically true
again and just yeah there's just a lot
in this chapter in that book yeah i i i
did it's it makes me very i was doing it
while you're working on the tech stuff
yes so we actually just very very happy
we got it yesterday apparently
they have sold enough of them in advance
that the copies that we were supposed to
end up with got sent to other people so
anyway we have just seen it we're kind
of excited to just seen it hold it in
our hands very much so so we're not
going to read on conformity or religion
and ritual or sex drugs and rock and
roll and the sacred versus the
shamanistic we're saving that for those
of you who actually get the book but we
are going to read literally false
metaphorically true i am going to share
that
here it's three pages
cultural beliefs are often literally
false but metaphorically true
consider farmers in highland guatemala
who have a long-standing tradition to
both plant and harvest crops only when
the moon is full
this they say allows the plants to grow
stronger and resist insect damage
what possible protective capacity could
the phase of the moon have on crop
health presumably none but the phase of
the moon can synchronize the farmers
a full moon is effectively a giant sky
clock a keeper of time that everyone in
the region can see
if all farmers in the region believe
that a full moon has salutary effects on
their individual crops they will likely
restrict planting and harvesting to the
full moon and this will in fact benefit
everyone's crops just not for the reason
the farmers believe
a belief in the power of the moon to
directly affect crops effectively
satiates predators by concentrating the
harvest into brief periods during which
time crop predators cannot eat all of
everyone's crops
it is easy to dismiss many myths and
beliefs of old precisely because they
are literally false
indeed doing so is almost a sport among
some hard-headed people
take astrology
it is clearly beyond reason to imagine
that the stars that we see many of which
are thousands of light years away are
having a direct impact on human behavior
similarly it is beyond reason to believe
that a passal of angry gods is the
reason for tsunamis yet among the moken
those who believe in those gods survive
at higher rates and those who don't
and it is surely beyond reason to
believe that a full moon is protective
of crop health yet among guatemalan
farmers precisely that belief results in
more productive farming
in each case the belief is literally
false but metaphorically true
this means that the cover story isn't
true but when people behave as if it
were they prosper
this is how religion and other belief
structures spread
even if such things are not literally
true acting as if they are benefits
people sometimes it even benefits the
biodiversity and sustainability of the
land in which they live
in its modern tabloid form astrology is
bunk
but astrology has probably not been so
everywhere and for all time
if and this is a big if you control for
where a person was born might not the
time of year that they were born have
effects on how they develop and
therefore who they become
and aren't astrological signs just an
ancient way of keeping track of the
months more or less
if we look at astrology this way rather
than as a modern indulgence that is too
free of context and history to have
meaning it begins to look promising
is a newborn in a minnesota winter
exposed to the same pathogens and
activities as a newborn in a minnesota
summer
surely not
and sure enough there has been work done
to bear out this idea
culling idea culling data from over 1.75
million records at new york presbyterian
columbia university medical center for
people born between 1900 and 2000
researchers found clear correlations
between birth month and lifetime disease
risk for more than 55 different
conditions
with affected systems ranging from
cardiovascular to respiratory from
neurological to sensory the sheer number
and breadth of medical conditions that
vary in lifetime risk by birth month
should be enough to make a thoughtful
person rethink a wholesale rejection of
careful astrological thinking
for if there are demonstrable
differences in disease risk by birth
month why should we imagine that there
are no differences in personality
as an aside one prediction of this
approach to astrology is that if you
include both birthplace and date
astrology will have less power to
predict lifetime disease risk the closer
you get to the equator where seasonality
is much reduced from that in the
temperate zones
another prediction is that the more
person moves around as a child the less
predictive astrology will be for them
and if you don't include birthplace
astrology should have no predictive
power at all
distortions that help you survive and
thrive are adaptive myths and taboos
often make little sense to outsiders and
some of them are surely misguided even
counterproductive for those who honor
them
some surprisingly precise taboos are
likely over generalizations from an
actual event
among the kamayura of the brazilian
amazon the eating of scaleless fish is
forbidden for both pregnant women and
their husbands it may well be that long
ago a terrible fate befell a woman her
unborn child or her entire family after
eating a fish without scales and that
the fish was the only explanation that
stuck
similarly on the oat plateau of
madagascar in the village of mahatsunjo
there is a taboo against eating hammer
cops a close relative of pelicans
this taboo is directly tied to villagers
having seen one fly over just as a man
died
elsewhere in madagascar it is taboo for
young men to eat mutton before wooing
taboo for pregnant women to eat the meat
of hedgehogs or to walk through fields
of pumpkin taboo for a son to build his
home to the north or east of his
father's house
to our western sensibilities this seems
like superstition pure and simple
the word for taboo in malagasy fadi has
a complex meaning as well in batsma
sarika the language of the people of
northeastern madagascar fadi means both
taboo and sacred
that which is fadi is mandated by the
ancestors be it mandated that you don't
do it or that you do
despite the preceding examples many
believes myths and taboos are literally
false metaphorically true malagasy fadis
come cloaked in the language of gods and
ancestors but it is still easy to see
the wisdom in many of them if you simply
look at the prohibition do not build a
house over or against a new landslide do
not step on a dead dog as you might get
hydrophobia rabies do not divorce your
wife while she is pregnant
good advice
we predict those taboos that have lasted
the longest are most likely to be hiding
an important cultural truth in plain
sight beware chesterton's fatties the
old ideas i'm sorry beware chesterton's
bodies the old ideas may have hidden
truths and those truths may be difficult
to recover once they have been dismissed
joseph campbell observed that mythology
is a function of biology he was correct
as an evolved creature you are built to
succeed and sometimes that involves
telling yourself stories
finding yourself in a raft near the top
of a dangerously tall waterfall you
might be about to die
if you believe that the shores within
reach and paddle like hell you just
might make it
those deflated by long odds will leave
no trace belief can be the difference
between life and death
i believe you have all you have angered
both the old gods and the new with that
kind of reading yes i'm sure that will
um anger at least some proponents of
both the old gods and the new um
but i mean it
precisely because as is true of
everything in the book
we are
trying to weave our way carefully
[Music]
down a road
that understands the reality and
importance of history and reveals a path
forward or at least the beginning of a
path forward that has uh
that has the potential to reveal great
things which we can't even yet imagine
yep i mean in fact you know
as we present this in the book and as we
have mentioned periodically here
this activity whether it's writing the
book and
having people read it and discuss it or
us talking about ideas from it and other
things
is effectively a modern version of the
campfire around which
consciousness would have been practiced
and i think maybe we did not say up
front
that one of the implications of the
model of consciousness and culture that
we present
is that it reverses the natural
expectation about why consciousness
emerged so while consciousness has been
famously resistant to explanation if you
think of it primarily
as and we argue that it would initially
have evolved as a mechanism for
individuals to pool their cognitive
strengths and come up with uh an
emergent sum that is greater than uh or
an emergent hole that is greater than
the sum of the parts
then individual consciousness which we
all take to be primary because we
experience individual consciousness and
inter-subjective consciousness is
something that we only have in direct
access to the idea that we may share a
thought
is not as vivid as any thought that
either of us would have it's much more
powerful because there are two minds
involved in creating it but it is much
less visceral and so
our argument is that we have studied
consciousness incorrectly in science and
in fact this is reinforced just by the
practicality you can put an individual
into an fmri machine you cannot put a
group of people into an fmri machine and
see what is
shared in their cognition at least not
simply one of the big drum beats of the
book of course is a rejection a
recognition of the value of the
reductionism in modern science and
medicine
and also a rejection of its ubiquity of
mistaking that which can be easily
measured for
that which is the most important thing
in a system absolutely and so in in this
case it's not that we deny the existence
and the importance of individual
consciousness but we argue that it is
likely to have come second that you
build a model that allows people to pull
their consciousness together and then
once you have the tool that involves
knowing what is likely in someone else's
mind maybe because you placed it there
you now have a tool in which you can
have an argument with yourself you can
hold two ideas and compare them as if
you were two different minds comparing
notes
and in any case
we regard this as likely a solution to
many of the most difficult issues
surrounding consciousness just simply by
getting the evolutionary order of
operations correct
that's right
uh well that's um
that's what i've got for today
uh do you have anything else that you
want to wrap up with no i think we've
more or less covered the territory all
right
so um we will be back next week uh for
those of you listening or watching and
wanting to go you know outside or to
sleep depending on where you where
you're watching from or whatever it is
that you might want to do for those of
you who are uh watching live uh we will
be taking a break um hopefully just 15
minutes depending on the technical stuff
and then be back with our q a and uh you
can ask questions at the q a at
darkhorsesubmissions.com
and uh we
um enjoin you to join our patreons uh
brad is having another conversation on
his tomorrow
you can get some stuff that has a dark
horse uh branding on it at
store.darkrisepodcast.org
you can email logistical questions like
how did i do that again not i want them
to address this in the q a but
logistical questions to
darkhorsemoderator gmail.com
and please consider uh if you like this
actually liking it and sharing it and
uh and subscribing both to this channel
wherever you're watching it but it's uh
it's mirror channel on youtube or
odyssey depending on where you're
watching it and also darkhorse podcast
clips
which are amazing clip sky pulls
what he views as the most salient things
from each week's episodes and puts them
on the clips channel so if you have any
suggestions that you think would be
particularly make particularly good
clips this week things you would like to
share in a smaller form than the whole
podcast you can email those suggestions
as well to darkhorsemoderator gmail.com
have you suggested that maybe given that
the book is going to emerge on the 14th
of september that it would be a great
time for people who haven't already
ordered it to order their own copy so
that it arrives and they can
get in on the discussion that's right it
is available for pre-order now
everywhere apparently it's at pals one
of our neighbors just just pre-ordered
it at powell so that's our local amazing
independent bookstore um but it's you
know it's available at all the usual all
the usual suspects and um will be
available in audiobook as well um uk and
uk like
colonial territories i guess um it'll be
available maybe two days later i think
publication is september 16th um
but yes please please consider doing
that and before we see you again next
week
there will be we will be talking to some
other people about the book some other
podcasts will be beginning to emerge is
the title in the uk a hunter-gatherer's
guide to the 21st century or is it a
warm beer drinkers guide i know they
considered that briefly they sure did
but we pushed but right back yeah we
pushed right back it does have a
different um
cover but it's it's the same title
um all right until we see you next be
good to the ones you love eat good food
and get outside be well everyone
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you